unsere regierung ist ein freiheits
reichen werde die dänische regierung
gegen die krone panikmache kämpft
spricht unsere regierung von basis
schutzmaßnahmen am 20 märz soll ein
crooner maßnahmen feind aber es könnte
das ist noch nicht beschlossen ein
grüner basisschutz geben ich werde schon
wütend wenn ich nur das wort höre
basismaßnahmen was soll das bedeuten
nennen wir die maßnahmen jetzt
basismaßnahmen bei jede basis für
weitere corona maßnahmen fehlt auf
welcher basis möchte die politik unsere
grundrechte weiter einschränken es
reicht wir brauchen keine basis
maßnahmen sollen den studenten
ja da muss ich sagen ich stimme dir in
der these vollkommen zu und habe dafür
zwei erklärungen zum einen sagen neue
umfragen dass ungefähr zwei drittel der
deutschen nach wie vor an ihrer masken
pflicht festhalten wollen weil sie sonst
total sich wahrscheinlich allein
gelassen fühlen und
freiheit hat in diesem land keiner
richtig große lobby mehr die freiheit
ist eine minderheit und die mehrheit
sucht den starken staat nach wie vor und
der staat wiederum das ist die andere
seite will uns nicht loslassen hat sich
angewöhnt die politik die regierung dass
sie über jahre hinweg den leuten gesagt
was sie zu tun und zu lassen haben und
das war so angenehm das lässt man so
bald nicht los und man bereitet sich im
kopf auch schon darauf vor dass man von
der masken pflicht im herbst nächsten
herbst wenn es wieder losgeht mit einem
neuen virus dann gleich wieder vollgas
gibt und wieder die anderen sachen drauf
legt mich widert das an ich habe mir
schon überlegt aber ich bin noch nicht
so weit ob ich das in zivilem ungehorsam
einfach verweigere und mal ausprobieren
wenn ich ohne masken ein supermarkt
eingehen was dann passiert ich habe
jedenfalls keine lust mehr ich bin
brillenträger im winter hast du ständig
eine beschlagene brille wenn du ein
brötchen kauft und mir reicht es jetzt
und dass leute so verängstigt sind dass
sie sich ohne maske gar nicht mehr
bewegen wollen das ist mir so was von
fremd also tut mir leid ich bin sowieso
hat mich stark
entfremdet von den deutschen muss ich
sagen aber es kann doch sein dass
basismaßnahmen nicht unbedingt die
pflicht zu machen
es ist eine möglichkeit aber kann es
nicht so sein dass man da
wissenschaftsbasierte entscheiden sollte
was alle passiert wenn wir wirklich eine
situation bekommen ich will niemand weiß
wie eine eventuelle virus variante
aussieht ich bin total für loco ich bin
auch gegen die meisten gar keine frage
wie die möglichst schnell loswerden aber
es kann ja wirklich passieren dass wir
wieder eine zugespitzte lage haben und
dass leute die sich auskennen sagen die
maske schutz vor infektionen ist ich
will das nicht ausschließen und deswegen
finde ich die grundidee und ich muss
wirklich die regierung nicht verteidigen
zu sagen wir haben einen
instrumentenkasten aber das grundprinzip
der kern
die rechte des grundgesetzes die gelten
punkt aus ende und dann kann man unter
besonderen bedingungen einschränkt dass
das ist ja ins verdrehen gekommen es
gibt jetzt eine situation dass das genau
nie mehr passiert gibt es ja gibt's denn
unveränderte bedingungen gibt es noch
nicht also wir lassen alles nach bloss
das nicht und da muss ich sagen
ich liebe das ist das schlimme ist dass
es nicht verlassen musste noch nicht was
ist das für ein land wo die regierung
den bürgern nicht sagen kann ihr
entscheidet jetzt selbst der andere ihre
masken tragen fragt sie wenn ihr wollt
das kann ja auch eine empfehlung sein
fragt sie in der in den offenen
verkehrsmitteln trat sie im supermarkt
ab wie ihr müsst nicht und es ist doch
ganz sicher dass die meisten leute eine
maske dort tragen werden ich nicht aber
die meisten schon aber wenn der
supermarkt rappelvoll wäre würde ich
vielleicht auch wieder einer auf setzte
aber jedenfalls nicht vorgeschrieben wie
sowie so wurden denn schon lange vor der
pandemie in bestimmten arbeitsgebiet
masken getragen einfach völlig normal
war niemand würde bei einer op keine
maske tragen ist doch völlig normal so
und so sage ich basismaßnahmen heißt
doch nicht dass das alles bestehen
bleibt ich wünsche mir dass möglichst
nichts bestehen bleibt aber zu sagen wir
haben jetzt wirklich einen
instrumentenkasten in den ganz positiven
sinne das finde ich nicht so fahrung
schaffen es dann andere länder als ist
schweiz zum beispiel erst jetzt auch die
maßnahmen alle fallen seit gehört in
england hat es gemacht schweden ist ganz
anders durch die panne gekommen als wir
muss man sich langsam auch mal sagen
zurück mit unserer freiheit ich meine
virus ist er nicht in deutschland so
sehr anders als in england und anderen
ländern in england war ich zum beispiel
das war ein tolles wochenende ich habe
die maske nicht einmal tragbar wissen
sie was ich so toll fand erwartet das
verständnis füreinander ein streit im
supermarkt manchen maske auf manche
nicht und das meine ich damit und bei
dieser basis maßnahme könnte es wirklich
sein dass die maske weiterhin
verpflichten bleibt zum beispiel in
innenräumen und das muss ich wirklich
sagen darf eigentlich mit blick auf die
aktuelle woche und ich gerade junge
leute die vielleicht 14 15 sind in der
schule sind und jetzt mit basismaßnahmen
aufwachsen und weiter wachsen und immer
ihre maske in der tasche zu haben das
finde ich hat nichts mit einem jungen
geführt zu tun und ich finde das hat
mehr damit zu tun angst zu verbreiten
eben nicht den respekt oder oder das
verständnis füreinander zu haben sondern
finde ich spaltet unsere gesetze ich
kann überhaupt wenn ich das mal
dazwischen werden darf ich kann den
begriff maßnahmen ich kann das ist ein
spezial begriff des hässlichen start der
maßnahmen ergreift gegen seine bürger
der dies und jenes vor sparmaßnahmen ist
eigentlich in einem nach meinem gefühl
von der sprache her in einem
demokratischen liberalen staat nicht
mehr möglich das substantiv maßnahme
muss man nicht wählen man kann auch
regeln nennen ja wir haben wir haben
einmal ja doch wir haben nur sehr sehr
viele regeln in deutschland wir haben so
viel gesetz bücher ja und hier finde ich
sollte man regularien aufstellen die
möglich sind und die angewendet werden
können und ich bin ja immer ein
vertreter gewesen der gesagt hat ich
liebe leute lasst uns nicht das für alle
gleich machen sondern wirklich in
besonderen situationen
ich habe ja ein beispiel gesagt niemand
etwas dagegen hat bei jeder op wird eine
maske getragen
das war schon früher so ja und da würde
niemand sagen maske ist quatsch so und
so sage ich auch zum beispiel in
altenheimen kann es sein dass es
sinnvoll ist weil die leute in so
gefährdet sind dass man sagt okay hier
müssen diejenigen die dort arbeiten eine
maske tragen ich sehe ja am beispiel bei
kindern ganz anders war da die in der
ersten zweiter klasse sind das eine ganz
andere situation
aber wenn eine pandemie wieder
gefährlich werden soll das ist ja jetzt
nicht das ist doch das entscheidende
problem das was bei delta war es bei
omikron nicht mehr da dann wird
teilweise etwas erzählt was ihm nicht
mehr der wahl stehen kommen die
basismaßnahmen damit die leute haben an
liegt vorne dass sie kommen es wird
gesagt wir haben inzwischen reisen
kassen und ob da irgendetwas angewendet
wird wir haben doch bei vielen anderen
dingen auch die möglichkeit
rechtsstaatlich zu agieren und machen es
nicht aus guten grund nannte denn die
linke bei einer solchen abstimmung
dagegen stimmen unter welchen
bedingungen oder nur die fdp die fdp
wird ja gerade nicht dagegen stellen
aber normale b-klasse glaube ich dass
alles tapfer mittragen weil das wird ja
im bundestag jetzt behandelt sehr sicher
ich finde naja das für mich ist
entscheidend wie wir das nicht mehr wie
wird das überhaupt ausgestaltet dass
doch die frage ist es so welche
teilweise vermutet dass dann diese
maßnahmen gelten oder ist es so dass ist
die möglichkeit besteht unter bestimmten
bedingungen daran dass danach bestimmt
möglich nur ich möchte es wirklich
verstörend weil es mich so wütend macht
als bürgerin ich möchte es wirklich
verstehen auf welcher grundlage dürfte
der staat jetzt überhaupt wir können auf
die hospitalisierung blicken wir können
die inzidenz werte vergleich in der
schweiz sind sie höher als in
deutschland auf ein auch die massen also
auf welcher grundlage
auch wenn man sich die ganze pandemie
anschaut und ab gerade auf welcher
grundlage darf der staat wenn die basis
schutzmaßnahmen jetzt beschlossen noch
über mich bestimmen ob ich zum beispiel
die maske tragen oder nicht mit wie
viele menschen ich mich treffe ich
verstehe es nicht mehr naja also gar
finde ich zum beispiel die
hospitalisierung rate und wenn denn die
intensivbetten ich sage mal zu 80
prozent belegt werden sind ja nicht dass
er die wirklich die geschichte die
einfach nicht stimmt zehn prozent sind
jetzt mit komapatienten belegt von die
intensivbetten wenn das aber richtig
hoch gehen sollte und wir in die
situation kommen dass wir es nicht mehr
bewältigen können dann ist die
möglichkeit auch
massnahmen klasse haben jahres nicht mag
so eben daran gibt es aber eine basis
regeln mehr sage ich jetzt mal sondern
ganz ganz andere herten was machen wir
denn machen wir uns so richtig schneit
was machen wir denn wenn so richtig
schneit dann rollen die sogar die
sogenannten basis maßnahmen sollen doch
jetzt den staat und die in angst und
schrecken versetzten über den sommer
hinweg tragen bis der herbst kommt dass
damit wir uns nicht entwöhnen in
freiheit ist das einzige land wo zum
beispiel niemand wird die maske gefallen
ist das macht mich übrigens besonders
wütend alles geliebt in anderen in
holland oder in österreich mal
wenigstens ein bisschen frei zu haben im
sommer davon wir haben einfach alles
glas nicht dass das das sehe ich als
wirklich großes problem dass man eben
wirklich in der natur wirklich nur maske
tragen soll das ist einigermaßen absurd
dass teile ich meinen randolph ich sehe
das als besondere für mich spielen da
wie generell in der pandemie diejenigen
die wirklich die verlierer sind sind
häufig kinder und jugendliche
insbesondere kinder und da für mich ist
viel zu wenig gemacht habe
gesagt dass ich meine nicht wieso heißt
eigentlich sowieso noch voll zu
verteidigen also wie der begriff heißt
es mir ehrlich gesagt wurscht mir geht
es darum ein regularium zu haben wenn es
wirklich zu
pandemischen neuen spitzen kommt dass
man agieren kann